nous sommes exceptionnelles.
On peut faire davantage.
Et de plus, au Malawi,
et non seulement au Malawi, mais dans d'autres pays :
la législation qui existe,
savez-vous qu'une loi ne l'est pas vraiment si elle n'est pas appliquée?
La loi qui vient d'être adoptée
et les lois qui existent dans d'autres pays,
il faut les faire connaître au niveau local,
au niveau de la communauté,
où les enjeux à l'égard des filles sont frappants.
Elles font face à des défis très difficiles dans la communauté chaque jour.
Si ces jeunes filles connaissent l'existence des lois pour les protéger,
elles seront capables de se défendre,
parce qu'elles savent qu'une loi les protègent.
Je veux dire une autre chose :
les voix des filles et des femmes
sont belles, elles sont là,
mais on ne peut pas le faire tout seul.
Les hommes doivent défendre, ils doivent participer,
intervenir, pour travailler ensemble.
Il s'agit d'un effort collectif.
On veut ce que les filles ont besoin partout :
une bonne formation et surtout le choix de ne pas se marier à 11 ans.
Et de plus,
je sais qu'ensemble,
on peut transformer le cadre légal,
culturel et politique
qui nie les droits aux filles.
Aujourd'hui je suis devant vous
et j'affirme qu'en une seule génération, on peut mettre fin au mariage d'enfants.
C'est le moment
quand une fille et des millions de filles partout dans le monde,
disent :
« Je me marie quand je veux. »
(Applaudissements)
Merci. (Applaudissements)